Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
[On m'a dit qu']il fallait parler du vivre
ensemble à la fin du Moyen Âge.
C'est une sorte de challenge.
Mon propos sera donc centré
sur le fait de vivre avec les malades.
Vivre avec la maladie,
vivre avec les malades,
voilà une question qui agite notre société
et qui s'est posée aussi
dans des temps plus anciens,
et pour des maladies bien plus terribles
que celles que nous connaissons.
Ainsi en fut-il de la lèpre en Occident
à la fin du Moyen Âge,
disons entre le 12e et le 14e siècle.
Deux éléments sont ici à prendre en compte
d'emblée.
Un, l’espace.
L’espace qui correspond
à la chrétienté latine.
Et deux, le champ chronologique
qui est marqué par ce qu'il
faut bien appeler une pandémie.
L'attitude des populations
à l'égard de cette maladie,
à l'égard de la lèpre et des lépreux,
dans la chrétienté occidentale
était conditionnée par deux facteurs.
Le premier de ces facteurs,
c'est la peur -
quelque chose que nous connaissons.
La peur, car la lèpre, dont l'agent
pathogène est le bacille de Hansen,
est une maladie qui prend
des formes spectaculaires et horrifiantes.
Le malade est défiguré,
les membres sont attaqués, sont rongés,
le malade est mutilé.
Donc une vision terrifiante.
Par ailleurs, le mécanisme de propagation,
de transmission par contact,
était bien compris, était bien connu, même
si la contagion était évidemment inconnue.
On avait bien compris
qu'on attrapait la lèpre par contact.
Cette peur était donc nourrie
par ces éléments
et cela conduisait, sinon
à l'exclusion, au rejet,
du moins à une volonté
d'éloignement du malade.
La question se posait d'autant plus que
la lenteur relative
de l'évolution de la lèpre
faisait que la masse des malades
était quantitativement importante.
Un autre facteur conditionnant
le comportement des populations
à l'égard de la lèpre et des lépreux
est un facteur culturel et religieux.
Pour le Chrétien médiéval,
la lèpre pouvait être envisagée
selon deux approches,
toutes les deux influencées
par les Saintes Écritures.
La première approche implique le rejet.
Dans la loi mosaïque, le malade
atteint de la lèpre est impur.
Il doit être séparé des gens sains.
Cette exclusion pour impureté se justifie
non seulement en raison de la
contamination, de la contagion,
mais aussi parce que
la lèpre était considérée
comme un châtiment frappant un pécheur.
Ce mal qui ronge et qui défigure
est vu comme une allégorie du péché.
La seconde approche
pour la chrétienté médiévale -
pour le Chrétien médiéval
implique au contraire
la compassion et l'accueil.
La rigueur de la loi, telle qu'elle
s'exprime dans l'Ancien Testament,
est adoucie par le message évangélique.
Le Christ ne craint pas d'approcher
les lépreux, de toucher les lépreux.
Il les guérit de leur mal en affirmant
que c'est la foi qui les sauve.
Il montre non seulement le lien
entre la lèpre et le péché
et en ceci, il est en parfaite cohérence
avec l'Ancien Testament bien sûr,
mais il montre aussi le lien
entre guérison et pardon.
Le lépreux n'est pas un réprouvé :
c’est l’image de l’humanité pécheresse
que le Christ est venu guérir.
« Ce ne sont pas ceux qui se portent
bien qui ont besoin du médecin,
mais le malade, » lit-on dans Marc, 2:17.
Le message est renforcé par saint Paul.
Saint Paul qui affirme :
« On doit honorer plus grandement
les membres les plus souffrants. »
C’est dans la première lettre
aux Corinthiens, 12:22-23.
Cette ambivalence, exclusion - compassion,
va prendre une dimension nouvelle
à partir de la seconde moitié
du 12e siècle.
En Occident, en effet,
on assiste à ce moment-là
à une véritable explosion de la lèpre,
sans doute venue d'Orient.
Dès lors se pose la question de l'attitude
à adopter face à une maladie
qui frappe un très grand
nombre de personnes,
et pas seulement des étrangers
ou des inconnus,
mais aussi des voisins,
des amis, des parents.
Certes, la peur, la répulsion,
le rejet de l'impureté
sont à l'origine de mesures d'éloignement,
parfois spontanées,
parfois dictées par des autorités,
que ce soit des autorités princières,
seigneuriales ou urbaines.
Mais dans une société chrétienne,
comme celle de l'Occident médiéval,
le rejet total des malades
est incompatible avec la morale.
C’est donc de l’Église d’abord
que vient une réponse qui
n'est pas dictée par la peur,
mais qui est le fruit
d'une double préoccupation :
accueillir ceux qui souffrent
et encadrer tout le peuple chrétien.
Or, le rejet ou l'éloignement des lépreux
les coupe de leur famille,
de leur paroisse,
de leur cadre social habituel,
en condamne un certain nombre
à l'errance et à une survie aléatoire.
Aussi, lors du concile de 1179,
concile général tenu à Rome
en l’église Saint-Jean-de-Latran -
ce concile que nous appelons
le concile de Latran III -
il est édicté, il est décidé
que dans tous les diocèses,
sous la responsabilité de l'évêque,
devaient être créés des lieux d’accueil
appelés maladreries,
c'est-à- dire léproseries -
organisés comme des cellules chrétiennes.
Cellules chrétiennes avec
une chapelle, un cimetière,
exemptées de la dîme et disposant
de lieux d'hébergement adaptés,
souvent de petites maisons
qu'on appelle des loges.
Cette mesure conciliaire
va rencontrer un grand succès.
D'une part, les fidèles
de toutes conditions,
conscients du problème aigu
que représentait cette maladie,
vont faire des dons en terres,
en rentes ou en argent,
et nombre de léproseries vont
se constituer un temporel important.
D'autre part, des fidèles,
hommes et femmes,
se portent volontaires
pour servir les lépreux
dans des communautés
de frères et de sœurs servants.
De ce point de vue, il faut rappeler
que, à l'aube des années 1200,
le premier engagement de François
d'Assise fut d'aller servir en léproserie
alors que, de son aveu même,
dans son testament,
il explique que la vue des lépreux
lui avait été jusqu'alors insupportable
et que cette conversion
est un signe tout à fait
clair de sa vocation :
aller vers les plus souffrants,
vers les plus pauvres,
aller vers ceux qui sont éloignés,
qui sont rejetés.
Cette conversion fut par la suite,
comme vous le savez sans doute,
représentée allégoriquement
par « le Baiser au lépreux ».
On raconte que François d'Assise a
rencontré un lépreux et l'a embrassé.
Ainsi, l'Occident se dote
d'un réseau de léproseries
placées sous le vocable de saint Lazare
ou de saint Nicolas,
implantées à la périphérie des villes,
en bordure de route,
de manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
une rupture totale
entre le lépreux et son milieu familial,
son milieu social habituel.
Les liens familiaux et sociaux
ne sont pas rompus de cette façon-là.
Ces institutions de création d'abord
épiscopale, puis princière et urbaine,
permettaient un regroupement,
un encadrement religieux et des soins.
C'était aussi un moyen de contrôle,
car le lépreux nomade,
le lépreux gyrovague, était
un personnage qui vivait
en dehors des cadres de la société,
était soupçonné d'inconduite et considéré
comme potentiellement dangereux.
Rappelons toutefois que
les lépreux qui étaient en maladrerie,
les lépreux qui étaient en léproserie,
n'étaient nullement confinés.
Ils avaient l'autorisation
de sortir de leur léproserie.
Ce n'est pas un enfermement.
Ils avaient le droit de sortir
et de circuler.
Le statut juridique des lépreux,
tel qu’il est décrit à la fin du 13e
siècle par Philippe de Beaumanoir,
un juriste qui avait été bailli
de Clermont-en-Beauvaisis,
est en tous points comparable
à celui des moines.
C'est ce que dit Beaumanoir :
« Comme le moine,
le lépreux est mort au monde. »
Il est mort au monde
et donc doit tout abandonner.
Il doit léguer ses biens.
Il conserve toutefois
des privilèges judiciaires
et jouit d'une protection juridique.
Par exemple, le lépreux est,
dit-on, « hors de toute guerre ».
On ne doit pas faire peser, par exemple,
une guerre privée contre des lépreux.
Donc il y a des privilèges judiciaires
et juridiques qui sont maintenus.
L'éloignement de l'espace urbain
est justifié, comme dit Beaumanoir,
« pour préserver les personnes saines
des enfers de la lèpre. »
Ce sont les termes qu'il utilise.
Mais il est loisible à ceux qui le veulent
d'aller vers les lépreux,
de les fréquenter, d'aller les voir.
Et de ce point de vue-là,
la cliquette du lépreux
ou le vêtement spécial qu'il revêt
en entrant en léproserie
sont des signes
qui permettent de l'identifier.
Quand on veut aller vers le lépreux,
on y va en toute connaissance de cause
car on a des signaux sonores -
la cliquette -
ou des signaux visuels - le vêtement -
pour savoir à qui on a affaire.
Ainsi, la société médiévale a mis
en place des structures d'accueil
et a aménagé le Droit pour répondre
à une situation difficile.
Il s'agissait de concilier des mesures
de précaution et l'esprit évangélique.
Le dualisme peur-charité,
répulsion-compassion,
n'a toutefois jamais disparu.
Les comportements ont varié et il ne faut
pas imaginer un rejet total et unanime.
Il est des villes comme Rouen,
par exemple, ou Périgueux,
admettant les lépreux dans leurs murs.
Ils ont droit d'entrer dans la ville
et les familles, on le sait,
conservent des liens réguliers
avec ceux de leurs membres
souffrant de la maladie -
telle épouse, qui va
périodiquement, par exemple,
laver le linge de son mari lépreux.
Vous voyez qu’on est loin d’une certaine
vision d’exclusion complète du lépreux.
Mais l'histoire tourne mal.
La longue crise du 14e siècle,
commencée dans les années 1315-1317,
est une crise à la fois sanitaire,
sociale, économique.
Et cette crise, cette période, vont voir
une dégradation de l’image des lépreux.
Leur caractère repoussant et mortifère
va l'emporter sur l'image
du pauper christi,
du pauvre du Christ, du membre souffrant.
Le contexte est en effet marqué, notamment
en France, mais pas seulement en France,
par des troubles politiques,
une grave famine et des épidémies
qui précèdent - j'y insiste -
qui précèdent la peste noire de 1348.
C'est ainsi qu'en 1321,
une rumeur accuse les lépreux
de fomenter un complot
pour empoisonner les puits afin
de contaminer les personnes saines.
Cette rumeur de complot va conduire
à des violences, à des homicides
et même à des exécutions
commandées par la justice.
Une fois de plus, c'est l'Église
qui intervient pour calmer les esprits.
Mais l'épisode montre bien un changement
conjoncturel dans les mentalités.
Dans les périodes difficiles,
vous le savez,
le bouc émissaire a toujours son utilité.
Toutefois, la crise une fois passée,
on observe un retour à la normale.
Les fondations de léproseries,
les dons charitables, l'acceptation
de la coexistence ne disparaissent pas.
Il est vrai que la fin du 14e siècle
voit une baisse de la tension
due à la diminution du nombre des lépreux.
Cette diminution du nombre
des malades atteints de la lèpre
n'est pas due, comme
on pourrait le penser, à une baisse
de la virulence du bacille,
mais en réalité, ce qui fait
la grande différence,
ce qui va conduire à une baisse
considérable de la population des lépreux,
c'est la peste noire de 1348.
Cette maladie infectieuse, qui est
d'ailleurs accompagnée d'autres,
frappe particulièrement brutalement
une population physiquement vulnérable
et en outre vivant en communauté.
Il n'en reste pas moins que face
à une maladie comme la lèpre,
la compassion pour l'être souffrant,
la reconnaissance implicite
de la dignité de l'individu
se sont manifestées plus,
finalement, que la peur et le rejet.
Nous pouvons considérer que
c'est une leçon que nous donne
cette période médiévale, si souvent
décrite comme une période brutale.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)